food probably tasted [__] back in the
day that's be that's probably why it was
fire huh that's probably why it was so
good cuz they had nothing else to
compare it to they have nothing else but
you get like some soup bone broth you're
like damn
okay sound like a
[Music]
Pikmin you remember growing up and it
was like I don't know I I know I'm not
sure about you Joe but pretty sure about
you Connor huh where I think Sydney had
a similar experience where you just
didn't have as much experience to a lot
of of the different world Cuisines that
were just in your area you should call
me white yeah it's
fine call me white God it's fine no no
no but there but there are like plenty
of Cuisines now that I did not have did
not ever have growing up like Korean
being one of them for example yeah I
mean for sure where I'd never had a
craving for Korean food because I never
tasted Korean food but now that I have
tasted it and I know what it tastes like
every so often I get the craving for it
that I just did not have growing up I
think I'd be you can say that about
anything though that you first
experience and you enjoyed like you say
that about alcohol what I'm saying is
that when we were growing up and we
didn't have this like worldview of like
all the different things that we tried
we were [__] content man I think I I
told the story once on the podcast I
still get cravings for a dish that is
just un unsavable it was just mashed
potato with corned beef and just mashed
up I [__] always want to eat this I
mean that kind of sounds fire going to
Li actually it's so good it's so good
I've come around to corn beef recently
just because like I never like my my my
parents like never like cooked with corn
beef like we never had any corn beef dis
like the shittest meat known to man
right and it's like and then when I
started hanging out with Ari and I
realized oh corn beef is like the staple
Filipino food to have cuz it's you know
it's very yeah that's when I realized I
was like oh it's actually kind of fire
and now every now and then I get
cravings for like corn beef based like
dishes dude try it corn beef or S spam
which is The Corned
pork uh try that just mash it into a
bunch of mashed potato it's actually so
good and I as a kid I used just eat
plates of this thing I would clean it up
so good I want to eat it there was there
was always that one like food item that
I think like every kid was I still think
beans on toast is fire beans on toast is
actually so good for me it was
salami that's not
controversial Everyone likes salami like
the cuts from like everyone loves
salami everyone loves salami my sister
didn't like salami what the [__] she was
a ham girl I think you're going to tell
me something weird like no I weird yeah
that okay I'll accept thatz salami is
just generally loved there's a lot of
Japanese people have never had salami
before that's C it's not C do you guys
like blue cheese [__] no yeah [__]
love blue [__] awful it's [__]
awesome it's like gash in my mouth no
it's [__] awesome because like you
know you you have this like no we
imagine your friend farting in your
mouth 24/7 while
E I just enjoy the fact that a lot of
people are just like ew Nat you let it
ferment in the ground and then you eat
that [__] and it's slimy and then here I
am in the Western World being like Oh
yeah blue cheese exists where we just
made cheese and then we just left out
for too long and people were like I
think I think because I grew up with so
much like fermented stuff like like you
know uh huan which is just fermented
radish or like you know Nat which is
fermented soy beans that like anything
that was fermented I was just like yeah
this is fine this is normal oh God I
just grew up with that kind of diet like
I would wake up in the morning I
remember like when I was at my my
grandparents house I would wake up in
the morning my my grandma would have
like a bowl of rice with some Misa
[__] big bowl of n my granddad would
make fresh like uh like you know the the
the Blended squid with the was can't do
that that was my breakfast like when I
was a kid and you know everybody else
who looks at that would be like what the
[__] that shit's nasty but for me that
was like that [__] is nasty to me for me
that was the staple breakfast and now
like anything that is fermented for me
now I'm like yeah it's it's fine it's
just [__] fermented who cares it's
good it leave in the door yeah it's fine
the longer it's the longer it's there
the better it is honestly if I had to
live off just tea and bread I could do
it I believe it I could just live off
tea and bread the most British thing you
ever said genuinely if you just gave me
a loaf of bread every day and some tea I
think i' be no complaints PE out of me I
could not do that you you know the
biggest reason why I think the massive
bread thing became a thing for me
because like I acknowledge now bread
tastes great don't dare say what you're
about to say I think like bread tastes
great but I can't like reprogram that
part of my brain that puts bread in like
a different category as like what you
would eat as like a main course you know
well as in like you can't look at bread
as a main cause yeah like bread to me
fits that same mental category as rice
does where I'm like if I if I eat a meal
of rice that's like a really depressing
meal for me I need something to go on
with that rice that's that's the Asian
mindset
bro like it's it's something that is is
paired with something that adds and
enhances the flavor of the rice you know
or of the bread like it's like having
bread in Europe was great but I'm like
this is a great starter for what what's
about to come you know yeah and I agree
with that do you know do you know how I
know anyone who goes like this is the
biggest test right when when someone
goes to a really like high class [__]
restaurant and the only thing they can
talk about is how good the bread was
that's how I know it was an overpriced
meal man that's that's that's like the
big literally 90% of the Italian
restaurants might be
in just so so many times I I like I
talked to someone who goes to like a
melin star restaurant and I'm like yo it
was the best bread I've had in my life
man and I believe it I believe it but
I'm like okay but like how was the rest
of the meal tell tell me how the rest of
how click bait you to the restaurant bro
it's like yo this this the food is like
kind of weird experimental and it's like
it's it's pretty splitty when it comes
to the opinion but the bread baset they
throw at you fire yeah that was the best
bread all the time baby put some
balsamic with some o like you know olive
oil on that [__] fire I think can be a
main if you need it to be say that's a
European in you bro like I can't I can't
do that I think just slice bread is
pretty fire I mean sliced bread can be
fire but if I have just sliced bread I'm
I'm I'm going to be like all right
where's the meal that's the equivalent
of being like you know that that bowl of
rice was kind of Fire by itself that's
fair enough if you feel that way yeah or
like the plain noodles was kind of fire
you know like no one's doing that sh
like salted noodles that pretty is
lightly salted noodles are fire no you
don't I do I like lightly salted Noodle
No you don't hot sauce is the best
invention we ever made it's like zero
calories you can add it to anything it's
just great hot sauce yeah hot sauce
unless it's the Nando's extra hot sauce
there's no way it's zero calories
Tabasco is like zero calories that's not
hot sauce oh my god well you want it to
like burn your [__] make GES of hell
kind of yeah yeah but also it's probably
zero calories cuz you're not adding
you're not you're not emptying half a
bottle of Tabasco on your meal no I
think it's actually zero calories the
entire thing it's like very low look at
all is go zero calories it's like it's
like well I I can believe that it's very
low calories cuz I've seen like the
viscosity of it yeah it's water it's
just vinegar with like extra spice look
at up Kai 12 calories per 100 gr that's
so much that's yeah that's you could not
okay that's basic could not apply 100
grams of Tabasco Tabasco you basically
just be Downing Tabasco that point it's
great it just adds so much flavor to a
meal I agree and I used to not like
Tobasco sure I don't like Tobasco really
[__] I I love it now it's like can you
just like something on can you like just
one thing can we like can we like it God
no no all right no um is Tabasco a
condiment yeah 100% that's why he
doesn't like
it it's it like it like it Tabasco it's
like okay I don't put it on the same
level as ketchup I'm not going to like
really cuz I just genuinely hate the
taste of ketchup uh with Tabasco it's
it's always that's cap with Tabasco it's
always filled in that Gap
of like what should be a hot sauce but
not really being a hot sauce does I
don't want a hot sauce a hint of a hot
sauce just like I never want that give
give give me 100% or give me zero man
well sometimes you have a pasta and it's
like I don't want hot sauce added to
this but I just
want sprinkle of
flavor I don't I don't want to kick in
the ass I just want like a flick on The
Shins you know like it's it's it's not
like it's just like a little bit me as a
tie um if I need that I just put some
TI they're like oh would you like a meal
they're like yeah and then you hear them
blending 500 Peppers out back and
they're like all right this is the first
round Chuck that in your pet bro once
once you've had fresh peppers like once
you've had like fresh chilies on
something you like Tabasco is just like
[__] baby ien I haven't reached that
level when it comes to spiciness I'm
still baby steps right now yeah yeah
yeah and I'm just like I don't if like
if I want to kick I need I like I I I do
I I am privileged I need fresh like I
need I need chilies man like Tobasco
just doesn't do it for me um that that
is my that is just my taste palette
that's fair